les ha pasado que cuando se enteran que
alguien que destaca a nivel mundial es
el salvador les cuesta creerlo como que
por alguna razón nos cuesta creer que
alguien del salvador pueda hacer mejor
que las personas más talentosas del
resto del mundo e inmediatamente nos
preguntemos pero como de hecho eso es lo
que más me preguntaron a mí después de
ganar el oro panamericano en lima en el
en los panamericanos son el evento
deportivo más grande de todo el
continente el segundo más grande del
mundo después de las olimpiadas en toda
su historia el salvador solamente ha
ganado cuatro medallas de oro yo soy la
segunda mujer en conseguir uno por esta
razón la prensa está pisa sus portadas
con las palabras y medallas históricas
pero para responder a esa pregunta como
yo puedo decir bueno en mi caso fueron
25 años de sacrificios sueños rotos
lesiones lágrimas pero sobre todo muchos
giros inesperados que parecían estarme
alejando de mis metas pero que ahora al
ver atrás me doy cuenta que me estaban
labrando el camino hacia ellas
no inician la ignacio a los 5 años ese
deporte se convirtió en la cosa más
importante en mi vida
cada segundo que no estuviera estudiando
estaba entrenando por eso tuve una
infancia bastante poco usual fui a muy
pocas fiestas de cumpleaños pocas
llamadas pero lo que le sorprende a la
gente cuando les cuento es que de hecho
yo nací con la peor habilidad para el
deporte nací con una condición que se
llama lateralidad cruzada que afecta el
desarrollo motriz de una persona eso me
hacía torpe descoordinada mis compañeros
mis compañeras en gimnasia
lo hacían bromas me hacían burla
haciéndome sentir tonta lo cual me
quería pero más hiriente aún era que
también me lo hacían sentir las personas
de quien yo más anhelaba aprobación mis
entrenadores y llegaba a casa llorando
noche tras noche pero me repetía esto
sólo significa que tengo que trabajar
más duro que los demás
mis primeros años compitiendo no ganaba
ni un sexto lugar de 10 competidoras ser
de las únicas tres que se van a casa sin
una medalla a esa edad puede ser súper
desmotivante pero eventualmente comencé
a subirme al podio comercial en al
tercero segundo primer lugar hasta que
al fin un día los entrenadores
reconocieron en mí a un atleta con
potencial y me aceptaron en el equipo
nacional
en ese momento yo me sentía realizada
había logrado lo que había anhelado por
tanto tiempo la aprobación de mis
entrenadores me sentía cerca de la cima
y cuando toma la broma de la vida cuando
pensaba que las cosas no podían ir mejor
durante el entrenamiento sufrió una mala
caída rompiendo me completamente el
ligamento cruzado de la rodilla
izquierda
esta lección puede acabar con la carrera
deportiva de cualquier atleta me mando
directo al quirófano me hicieron una
cirugía reconstructiva me inmovilizaron
la pierna completa un mes cuando me
quitaron la inmovilización el músculo
estaba tan atrofiado que mi pierna de la
piel y hueso tuve que aprender a moverla
apoyarla a caminar a correr fue un año
doloroso de terapias después de ese año
de recuperación regresé al gimnasio y al
año de haber vuelto me sentía fuerte
otra vez estábamos a un mes de los
juegos panamericanos del 2004 y el
entrenador me dijo paulina si vamos acá
en este elemento vos podés ir a los
juegos panamericanos un primero de
octubre era día del niño el entreno
terminó temprano para festejar nos el
día del niño pero yo decidí quedarme
entrenando extra sola para sacar ese
elemento para ir a los juegos
panamericanos de las ocho y media de la
noche por fatiga sufrí otra mala caída
rompiéndome completamente el ligamento
cruzado de la otra rodilla eso dije a
tirada en el suelo yo
lloraba gritos no porque dolía si dolía
pero porque sabía lo que acababa de
pasar sabía lo que tenía y en efecto
directo al quirófano cirugía
inmovilización y un año completo de
terapias de recuperación después de ese
año
intenté volver una tercera vez pero para
esta ocasión los entrenadores ya no me
aceptaron en el equipo nacional
yo ya estaba demasiado lesionada así que
decidí quedarme entrenando sola entrene
sola seis meses hasta que poco a poco
fue llegando a la dolorosa realización
que mi cuerpo ya no me rendía igual y
poco a poco se fue apagando esa llama
que me caracterizaba de persona
apasionada perseverante hasta que un día
se apagó por completo y no volví
a esto le siguieron un par de años en
los que me sentía perdida sin propósito
me habían quitado lo que era más
importante para mí
mejor estudiar artes a parís lo cual
suena muy glamuroso pero estuvo lejos de
hacerlo vivía un espacio del tamaño de
un pequeño ascensor
en ese espacio una cama chiquita justo a
la par una pequeña hornilla un paso
después estaba la ducha siempre habla
broma que podía cocinarlo de mi cama y
el baño era compartido estaba en el
techo del edificio a la intemperie así
que si yo quería ir al baño a las 3 de
la mañana me tenía que poner el abrigo
tenía que poner las botas tenía que
salir a la nieve estudiaba de madrugada
trabajaba de mesera desde lavando
trastes a trabando baños y había
momentos en que lo maldecía y me decía
porque ni siquiera estoy segura de que
quiero comida porque estoy haciendo eso
pero me recordaba que hasta las
experiencias que parecen ser malas son
aprendizajes y que ningún aprendizaje es
tiempo perdido un día me encontré con un
lugar que era una academia de paul vélez
por pura curiosidad entre y desde el
primer momento supe que era algo que
tenía que intentar en ese momento
se re encendió esa llama que se había
apagado a mis 14 años de persona
apasionada en ese momento yo me
reencontré si están preguntando que él
por fin es en un deporte acrobático se
realiza con una barra vertical es
deporte federado en muchos países del
mundo reconocido como deporte
oficialmente por el comité olímpico
internacional y también ha sido
incorporado en varios de los
espectáculos más prestigiosos del mundo
como lo es el circo del sol pero en
aquel entonces yo solamente lo conocí en
un contexto erótico el folk pero no iba
a permitir que el prejuicio me alejara
de experimentar cosas que me iban a
hacer crecer el vivir con prejuicio cómo
vivirla entre una cajita con
experiencias reducidas que no te
permiten evolucionar en cambio la
curiosidad te lleva a experimentar cosas
que te hacen crecer y fue la curiosidad
de lo que me llevó a mí a conocer el
polio
eventualmente regresa el salvador y bajo
ese mismo pensamiento de no permitir que
el prejuicio y la crítica de las
personas dictará mi vida decidí romper
tabúes y romper estigmas abriendo la
primera escuela de paul penes en el
salvador
todo iba bastante de maravilla hasta que
una cosa comenzó a molestarme y es que
había entrado en una zona de confort y
en una zona de confort no se crece
así que aplique a una beca
de estudio por trabajo en una academia
de paul y danza aérea en nueva york' y
para mi sorpresa me aceptaron en ese
momento sin pensarlo dos veces hice
maletas me subí a un avión y me fui a
nosotros mis sueños me mudé a nueva york
pero esa academia no tramitaba visa de
estudiante así que a la par también me
inscribí en una academia de danza
contemporánea que si me la tramitaba
pero tenía que recibir 24 horas de danza
a la semana aparte de las horas que
tenía que recibir de entrenamiento en la
otra academia de danza aérea y paul
aparte trabajaba en la academia haciendo
desde la recepción hasta la limpieza y
para costear mis gastos también
trabajaba de mesera hasta altas horas de
la noche y era bastante agotador pero me
repetía siempre que hasta las
experiencias que parecen malas son las
que te hacen crecer y te hacen aprender
y que el aprendizaje nunca es tiempo
perdido en esa época comencé a competir
como atleta de post fitness y algo que
les sorprende a las personas cuando se
los cuento ahora es que yo padecía de
pánico escénico
pero la ansiedad que yo sufría no era
una ansiedad normal de chiquita me
diagnosticaron obsesiva compulsiva y con
trastornos de ansiedad medicada durante
toda mi vida
un mes antes de competir comenzaba a
padecer de un insomnio tan insoportable
tan insoportable y desesperante que
comencé a acudir al alcohol para poder
dormir esa imagen mía sentada al área de
mi cama sola de madrugada acudiendo al
alcohol para poder combatir mi ansiedad
es algo que me avergüenza y me duele
recordar
para decir comencé a padecer de ataques
de pánico que me hicieron ir a parar al
hospital porque los los síntomas de un
ataque de pánico son físicos y se pueden
confundir con un ataque al corazón de
hecho en una ocasión iba en el taxi
hacia el aeropuerto un 24 de diciembre
para pasar la navidad en misión con mi
familia y me dio un ataque de pánico en
el taxi el taxista en media guerra para
del aeropuerto erró para el hospital
perdí mi vuelo y pasé sola la navidad en
una cuarto de hospital pero mi peor
ataque de pánico lo sufrí arriba de un
escenario a media coreografía durante un
campeonato en méxico me congelé sentí
todos los síntomas cuando al fin pude
moverme salí corriendo del escenario y
del teatro caí de rodillas y lloré por
horas prepararte por meses para esos
tres minutos arriba del escenario para
arruinarlo de la forma más tonta que ha
sido el punto más bajo de mi carrera
deportiva
una competencia no es algo de vida o
muerte para ponerse así pero cuando
sufrí de un trastorno de ansiedad
diagnosticado el más mínimo detonantes
basta para que te invadan los síntomas
yo estaba en un momento vulnerable e
inestable emocionalmente pero estaba a
un mes de volver a competir en buenos
aires pero en vez de retirarme me dije
no puedo permitir que un monstruo que yo
creé dentro de mi cabeza que ni siquiera
es tangible me aleje de conseguir mis
metas
entonces me subí al avión viajé a buenos
aires y esa competencia la gane pero no
una medalla ni siquiera me subí al podio
pero gane porque me subí complete mi
coreografía y ese día vence el monstruo
más dañino que puede enfrentar un ser
humano el que creamos dentro de nuestra
cabeza y se alimenta de nuestros temores
después de eso eventualmente regrese al
salvador seguí entrenándome sola era mi
propia entrenadora la cosa que más yo
temía haciendo mi propia entrenadora era
la mediocridad y el conformismo
esa pregunta está siendo conformista es
lo que empujaba mis entrenamientos más
allá de cualquier dolor o fatiga
eventualmente un día conocí al
presidente de la federación de
fisicoculturismo y conociendo mi
historial deportivo me dijo paulina tú
tienes el potencial para representar el
salvador en los juegos panamericanos sus
palabras fueron tú puedes hacer historia
en ese momento no sabía a qué se refería
pero sí sabía una cosa los juegos
panamericanos habían sido un sueño
inconcluso en mi vida y hoy 15 años
después la vida me estaba presentando
cuando yo menos lo esperaba y de la
forma menos desesperada la oportunidad
de cumplir con aquel sueño y yo no lo
iba a desperdiciar a eso le siguió un
año de dura preparación que ha sido de
las cosas más duras que vividas en mi
vida
la dieta es algo hay que hacer un
guerrero para hacer una dieta
fisicoculturismo
la dieta sigue volviendo cada vez más
estricta a medida que la intensidad de
los entrenamientos iba subiendo y mi
energía iba bajando cuando llegué a los
juegos panamericanos la alimentación nos
dijeron que iba a estar preparada tal
cual lo fisicoculturista la
necesitábamos y no era así sino seguir
el plan alimenticio una semana antes de
competir puedes arruinar el proceso de
meses así que la frustración era enorme
y literalmente lloré frente a las
personas de la cocina para que me
prepararon las cosas tal cual las
necesitaba hasta que accedieron pero los
obstáculos no terminaban ahí
panama ports la organización no tenía un
espacio adecuado para que las atletas de
mi deporte enseñaremos la coreografía lo
cual y acrobática de gimnasia
entonces me tocó ensayar la en concreto
provocando me tendinitis al tobillos y
muñecas el cambio de clima me había
provocado una gripe que me tenía afónica
con las energías por el suelo pero lo
que más me intimidó estando ahí fue
darme cuenta que las demás atletas
andaban acompañadas de su entrenador y
su coreógrafo y me di cuenta que yo era
completamente nueva en el deporte y
había montado mi coreografía sola la de
mascletás tenía experiencia en ese
deporte era mi primera vez toda ésta
cosas me hicieron sentir frágil
vulnerable derrotada negativa hasta que
un día y ese día descubrir de la forma
más explícita que nunca antes mi vida el
poder de las palabras me dije
paulina te estás victimizando las
personas que se victimizan no ganan los
que ganan son los que ven lo que pueden
hacer con lo que tienen y si ganas ese
oro va a ser aún más glorioso mientras
más sean los obstáculos que tenés que
vencerlo ese día mi energía cambio 180
grados
me sentí vencedora fuerte con esta
energía llega el día de la competencia
ese día yo lo recuerdo como un día de
película 'el salvador' iba en el puesto
49 del medallero penúltimo la derrota ya
se había asumido el salvador no cree en
su presencia las letras
y el último día de los juegos
panamericanos en las últimas tres horas
de los juegos pasó lo que nadie estaba
esperando cayeron tres oros uno tras el
otro la delegación entera se me pone la
piel de gallina recordaron gritaba
lloraba saltaba
tres oros otros países consiguen 40 60
pero otros países como canadá eeuu
méxico llevan 400 atletas y ciertos
atletas 500 atletas el salvador llevaba
59 y con 59 atletas consiguió tres oros
es algo enorme y es suficiente motivo
para sentir que podemos ser tan buenos o
mejores que cualquiera en el continente
o en el mundo
para finalizar quiero terminar con
pensamiento cuando yo me lesioné pude
haber dicho
tanto externos desperdiciando mi
infancia la gimnasia para terminar
lesionada pero si yo no hubiera sido
gimnasta
no hubiera agarrado el mes como lo hice
yo me fui a estudiar artes a parís y
terminé haciendo algo diferente y pude
haber dicho todos esos años y dinero
desperdiciando en una carrera pero si yo
no me hubiera ido a parís yo no hubiera
conocido el pool fitness y si yo no
hubiera conocido el pool peines no
hubiera agarrado el fitness coreográfico
y no sería el actual campeona
panamericana así que
si alguien les dice que pueden hacer
historia créanselo y mamás cuiden a sus
hijos que están hechos de sueños esta es
la historia de como yo llegué al coro al
final del arco iris muchas gracias
[Aplausos]